in every generation
there's a cinematic event that changes
everything this is unprecedented a
phenomenon that challenges the social
norm i've never seen anything like this
a spectacle that brings people together
while taking the world by storm if you
are told to evacuate make sure that you
seek shelter they say lightning never
strikes twice ah [ __ ] it who are we
kidding kill some sharks
it's happening again you really think
it's gonna be one of those shock storms
here yes
i'm not crazy people have to know the
truth before it happens again
welcome to new york it's like you know
who i was this is the big apple
something bites us
we bite back i almost love you once and
i'm not gonna do it again
let the fireworks begin
holy shark
they're getting closer
they're sharks they're scary no one
wants to get eaten
but i've been eating
and i'm here to tell you
it takes a lot more than that to bring a
good man
a down more than that to bring a new
yorker down
you know what you just did don't you
jump the shark
sharknado 2 the second one premieres
wednesday july 30th at 9. even the
sharknados are tougher in new york
only on sci-fi
you